I think it was a sort of major
achievement for UNIX, actually, that
y' know its big claim to fame is:
... yes we (Dennis and Ken) we wrote the UNIX
kernel in C. We had to have a few dozen
lines of assembler and maybe, somewhere
in there, there's the odd sprinkling of
gotos --  and there's good excuses for it,
sometimes, in the heart of an operating
system but they're, even then,
massively reduced from what they would
have been. So, that was the whole thing:  we
must eliminate gotos. You can call them
gotos, if you like, you can call them
jumps; you can call them branches. All
essentially resolve into being the same
thing. They ... and I think most of you - from
the education you're having already, or having
seen previous Computerphile videos, will
know that gotos, branches, jumps etc are
unavoidable at the assembly language
level. OK? That's the way that machines
actually work. You tell them to `goto' a different
[next instruction] address. So what's wrong with
incorporating that idea into
higher-level languages? Well, the argument
was - and it's quite right - the problem
with the goto is that programmers never [seldom?!]
adequately document alongside *why* they
are `going to' ...  A common construct, of
course, is to have a go-to at the bottom
of a loop to jump back to the top. You
check at the top whether you've
finished the loop or not. But in the end,
when it's finished, you do another goto when
you jump past it [i.e. the loop body] to the next
instruction. A good assembler program
will put a little note in there saying
`loop finished', or something like that, so
the argument is, well, that looping
construct, in a higher-level language,
could be replaced by a `while'. And if that
`while' is then compiled down into
assembler the gotos will be there, but
when you consult back with the high-level
language you know that it [the goto] was
there because it's a `while' loop. And that
is, basically, what it comes down to. By
using higher level constructs you make
your intentions plain.
This enables me to kill two birds
with one stone! Some of you are getting
very, very worried about unsolved Rubik
cubes. Now I left one here there's some
unsolved in a particular way that I hope I
can do, in real time now, without
embarrassing myself. This cube is
solvable with two operations called
Goto monotwists. Goto is a very common
Japanese surname and I'm guessing that
the Goto of Goto-monetwist fame must
have been a Japanese mathematician going
way back to the early 1970s when I first got this
from a set of notes [by David Singmaster] on how to
solve the cube. It always amused me, and I
always delighted in doing it, because there
is another Goto who was a
very famous Japanese computer
scientist. And to everybody's great
amusement - in the 70s or 80s - he was at a
conference saying: "You have no idea how
stressful it is to have the surname Goto
and to be involved in high-level
programming language design and analysis"
And people said: "But, Professor, why ... ? ".   He
said: "People are always trying to eliminate me!
So, anyway, back to the gotos. [looks at cube]
I see that that one, and that one, are needing a
twist - and you can get things that twist
on their own axis - but while leaving the
rest of the cube unchanged - or `invariant'
as mathematicians like to call it. You
can see that there's a sort of threefold
symmetry on these corners. You can do one
twist, two twists and when you've done
three twists you're bound to be back to
the same place. I can see from this one
that it's actually going to need a
couple of these Goto monotwist operations
[or one inverse monotwist], to get it to being perfectly
right. And I hope I can do them without
goofing up. If you write ... if you post a
comment on this please *don't* point out
that that this is heavily sub-optimal. Yes, I
know! There's brilliant [ but non-Goto] ways to
do it much more quickly I'm sure. So, I remember,
in group theoretical notation, [using ' to denote
"-1" i.e. an anti-clockwise move] it goes
something like R' D R F D F' U
F D' F' R' D' R U'
That's progress! There's still two things that
are wrong but they now have exactly the
same colour. And I know from my suboptimal
- but at least I can remember it (!) -
algorithm, that another Goto monotwist, given
they're both the same colour and provided
I don't goof up,  one more will get it
right. So here we go: - R' D R F D F' U.
F D' F' R' D' R U'. Yippeee!
Computer Scientists can do limited Group Theory
if they try very hard!
But it's not enough trespassing on
Numberphile territory. I cannot commit - and will not
commit to memory - the
something like 90 algorithms, I think,
that you've got to know, to be even moderately
good at doing a cube really, really
quickly. I tend to try and remember about
10 or 12 [algorithms] and accept that they're sub-
optimal - but I find them easier to remember!